well for the first time ever unlv and
unr will play on nevada day weekend and
for the first time the battle for the
fremont cannon played at allegiant
stadium
in front of fans too john treats reminds
us why this matchup means so much hey
john
that's right it's 545 pounds battleborn
and rivalry worn the john c
fremont cannon is the most expensive
trophy in college football
who knew one painted artifact could
solidify and separate north versus south
in red versus blue
tomorrow their cannon will only go to
one either nevada reno or nevada las
vegas will conquer
the cannon the last two seasons unlv had
miserable seasons all was seemingly lost
until the final game was
won the rebels roared to the greatest
comeback in school history
in 2018 erasing a three touchdown
deficit to stun the wolf pack
last year after their coach was fired a
three and eight unlv team
traveled to frigid sierra nevada and won
the first
overtime game in match-up history it's a
rivalry where the records
are meaningless but bragging rights and
canon possession
means everything the first member i had
was my freshman year they just blew us
out the water
it was like 45 out of 10 and watching
them
pull the cannon out um and you know just
spray painting it blue already on our
field was so disrespectful
and i just knew like this was like a
serious game and
we got to take them serious because when
it comes to it whoever pulls that cannon
out
is a special moment for them this gets
petty in a hurry between friends
unlv lost badly in their first game last
week unr won dramatically in overtime
but again nothing else matters but
tomorrow night
at allegion stadium